[Musique]
action j'aime pas tellement quand on dit
eq star du x parce que je trouve ça
hyper réducteur et je me suis jamais
sentie actrice en fait je me suis pas
baladé sur les plateaux du monde entier
à a tourné avec des acteurs que je
connaissais pas j'ai tourné avec deux
personnes est une personne que je
connaissais depuis cinq six ans mon
petit ami et une scène avec yann encore
une fois je les fais pour moi pour me
libérer certains vont avoir les poils
qui s'y risquent mais j'ai fait
pratiquement comme un acte féministe
d'une fille qui voulait se prouver à
elle même que son corps et son cerveau
lui appartenait qu'elle avait des choix
des droits des surtout la liberté de le
faire donc voilà on l'a fait on s'est
éclatés ça a duré un an j'ai fait une
scène avec ann scott effectivement la
fin de ma carrière vaut mieux pour faire
chez oxford une fois pour le calendrier
à la base c'était une blague hein
puis c'est devenu un best-seller en même
temps le jour où ça plaira plus je vais
pas pleurer janry vendu les calendriers
c'est le treizième
donc personne n'a fait ça c'est déjà
incroyable dit mon métier c'est celui de
l'exposition et celui de l'expression ça
fait 15 ans que je cultive cette image
un petit peu de la femme par excellence
donc je jeu sublime
l'image la musique comme si c'était un
peu une oeuvre d'art mais ça n'existe
pas en réalité je suis tout à fait
humaine ya une équipe derrière et on
travaille tous pour avoir une image
parfaite en tous cas à nos yeux je fais
rien de croire certainement pas que je
me lève comme ça parce que toute façon
personne ne veut y croire et ça ne
m'intéresse pas trop pour dire la vérité
puisque j'aime pas spécialement mentir
[Musique]
c'est vrai que ce qui va m'intéresser
davantage c'est plus le cinéma un peu
alternatifs ou au des scènes réelles
pour le coup pourquoi dire hard parce
que c'est le quotidien le faire l'amour
des scènes réelles où on voit les choses
sont intégrés à des films un peu barré
c'est au fur et à mesure des mois des
années que je me suis rendu compte de la
place que prôner le journal du hard dans
la vie de certaines personnes et
notamment dans les prisons
j'avais des gens qui sortent en dédicace
qui vont me voir en disant mais moi j'ai
été en prison tu te rends pas compte que
c'était vraiment leur rendez vous de la
prison vous avez le droit de pas de
regarder de films rien ils aideront le
journal du hard
[Musique]
déjà quelque chose qu'il faut savoir
c'est que quand j'ai fait du porno avec
mon petit ami à 15 ans j'avais 19 ans
donc finalement je n'avais aucune
expérience
je me suis améliorée depuis puisque j'ai
trente revin aujourd'hui et que
finalement ce que vous avez vu c'est
dommage que vous ayez retenu saba il ya
eu mieux après mais c'est d'abord vous